maria jose around usted es la hermana de
andrés araus que es candidato a las
elecciones presidenciales que se van a
llevar a cabo en ecuador en pocos días
más cuál día central de la propuesta de
su hermano para aspirar a la presidencia
ecuatoriana
pero no muchas gracias primero por esta
entrevista efectivamente de andrés
araujo es mi hermano y ahorita es el
candidato presidencial para las
elecciones en ecuador
las propuestas principales de andrés
consisten en la reactivación económica
entonces como usted sabe ahorita ecuador
está pasando por una crisis económica
sanitaria y social entonces la prioridad
se encuentra en restablecer una cierta
estabilidad para dar los ingresos
económicos a las familias ecuatorianas
entonces eso consiste en primeramente
dar un alivio económico a las familias
con una propuesta que está haciendo de
se llama mil de uno entonces es dar mil
dólares
y familias ecuatorianas a las más
afectadas las más vulnerables para que
puedan aliviar inmediatamente sus
necesidades este programa equivale al
pcb de aquí de canadá lo que todo se
ofreció justamente al inicio de la
pandemia es decir aliviar económicamente
a las personas más afectadas por la
pandemia también otra propuesta muy
importante es la vacunación entonces
éste también es de un eje principal de
las propuestas políticas de andrés de
arauz
andrés de alausí ya han negociado ya
tiene un acuerdo con argentina para la
distribución de la vacuna al llegar al
gobierno de ecuador entonces eso es algo
que andrés no ha esperado hasta llegar
al poder sino que ya está preparando ya
hay un cronograma de vacunación a partir
del mes de junio y se prevé en 22
millones de vacunas es decir para 11
millones de ecuatorianos
para quienes no conocen aquí en canadá
su hermano cuál es la experiencia que
tiene en el plano político ha sido
funcionario ya en su país
claro andrés a grados es una persona que
tiene experiencia en las políticas
públicas públicas y en la economía
financiera desde hace ya más de 15 años
ha estado trabajando en el gobierno y
como director general del banco central
como subsecretario de la secretaría de
planificación como ministro de talento
humano y conocimiento y también como
ministro de cultura entonces ha venido
formándose trabajando y con todos sus
conocimientos en favor para servir a su
país varias cosas
hace pocos días hubo un debate público
al cual se invitó a 16 candidatos para
las próximas elecciones no todos se
presentaron y uno de los ausentes fue su
hermano cuáles son las razones por las
cuales no asistió a este debate
bueno no sé de cual debate que usted
está mencionando porque hubieron varios
pero hubo solamente uno que fue oficial
es decir uno que fue organizado por el
cn que es del consejo nacional electoral
es decir fue el debate oficial y en ese
debate estuvo andrés a grados estuvieron
los 16 candidatos por obligación también
y fue transmitido por cadena nacional en
todo el ecuador y duró dos días se dice
es decir el debate se hizo en dos días
los otros debates hubieron se
organizaron por entidades privadas ya
fue más como una iniciativa privada y ya
no todos los candidatos fueron pero el
oficial andrés garau de estudio
el actual presidente del ecuador es
lenin moreno
quien en su momento fue señalado como la
persona propicia para ocupar la primera
magistratura por su predecesor en el
gobierno rafael correa luego comenzaron
los distanciamientos entre ellos dos
cuáles son las principales diferencias
entre andrés araujo y lenin moreno a
nivel gobierno oa nivel propuesta de
gobierno
no hay problema en las diferencias la
verdad es que son muy grandes
varias varias diferencias
andrés a 2 es tiene formación académica
extensa está haciendo su doctorado en
economía financiera en la unam tiene una
maestría en economía del desarrollo de
la flacso en ecuador y tiene una
licenciatura en economía y matemáticas
de la universidad de michigan una de las
mejores universidades del mundo entonces
tiene una formación académica también lo
que tiene es una coherencia política y
una ética
singular es yo crecí con él con mi
hermano en mi familia
y nosotros nos han criado con valores y
con principios y uno de los valores más
importantes que andrés tiene es la ética
y eso se ve en su vida personal y en su
vida profesional entonces él se ha
formado
para servir a su país desde un inicio
desde su más temprana edad ha estado
siempre pensando en cómo hacer para
ayudar a su país y cómo mejorar entonces
se ha formado todos los conocimientos su
experiencia es para esto empezó luego
con la revolución ciudadana trabajando
en el gobierno de rafael correa
este movimiento esta transformación
social impactó con la visión de andrés
entonces si andrés fuera como lenin
moreno y estuviera trabajando con él al
contrario cuando lenin moreno entró al
gobierno y se empezó a distanciar como
usted dice pero distanciar es poco
porque fue una traición no sólo a correa
o al movimiento político sino a toda la
población ecuatoriana andrés estaba en
mexico cursando su doctorado y ahí es
cuando él decidió fundar el observatorio
de la dolarización para justamente
hacer un análisis de las políticas
públicas y ofrecer soluciones y
propuestas constructivas al gobierno no
se tomaron en cuenta estas propuestas
pero esto demuestra es un ejemplo del
compromiso que andrés araus tiene hacia
su pueblo hacia el país y es otra
muestra por ejemplo que no está
esperando hasta llegar al poder para
tener un plan de vacunación ya se está
haciendo ya se hizo estuvo hace como dos
tres meses en argentina en argentina
donde es el país donde se van a fabricar
las vacunas de astrazéneca entonces
andrés ya tiene un acuerdo con argentina
gracias a alberto fernández y ya tiene
un cronograma está trabajando con las
especialistas de salud para esto
entonces
este tipo de cosas es lo que muestra el
carácter y los valores de andrés y que
demuestra su compromiso hacia su país
maria jose usted hablaba de la
vacunación
a raíz del tema de coronavirus y uno de
los temas que se debate siempre en
relación a esta pandemia es que muchos
sistemas de salud no han estado
preparados no solamente en américa
latina' en todas partes del mundo para
hacer frente a una situación de
emergencia como la presente además del
tema de vacunación tiene su hermano un
proyecto para reforzar un sistema de
salud al modelo de los sistemas de salud
públicos que abundan casi ya
excluyentemente en américa latina'
puesto que en otras partes del mundo
y aquí en canadá también pero hay otras
partes del mundo la salud se ha
privatizado absolutamente o casi
absolutamente y hemos visto cuál ha sido
la respuesta que esos sistemas han
podido dar a esta pandemia cuál es la
propuesta entonces que andrés araus
tiene
en lo que hace a un sistema de salud
integral más allá de esta pandemia
me alegra mucho a luís que me haga esta
pregunta porque yo misma soy una
profesional de la salud pública
salubrista y este tema es para mí muy
importante también la salud pública ha
sido extremadamente debilitada en el
ecuador desde la llegada del gobierno de
moreno
se habían trabajado diez años durante el
gobierno de correa durante la revolución
ciudadana para fortalecer un sistema de
salud público accesible universal y
gratuito y todo eso se fue a la basura
en cuestión de unos pocos años y eso
hemos sido víctimas
con la pandemia hemos visto como el
sistema de salud pública explotó no pudo
atender a los ciudadanos y ciudadanas
ecuatorianos y ecuatorianas lo vimos en
cuántas veces salieron imágenes de
cadáveres en la calle en guayaquil
porque no se tenía donde mandar a los
muertos por kobe el sistema explotó
entonces se vio la renuncia de la
ministra de salud diciendo no me están
dando los suficientes fondos para
manejar esta pandemia no puedo trabajar
así
no habían fondos si habían fondos
resulta que el gobierno estaba
preparando deuda externa que podía ser
pagada en el 2022 2023
se pagó en el 2020 anticipadamente en
vez de atribuir esos recursos a la salud
pública no se pagaron salarios de
médicos de trabajadores de la salud
tuvieron movimientos manifestaciones de
trabajadores de la salud porque no han
sido pagados eso es imposible no se
puede decir entonces el sistema de salud
pública está extremadamente debilitado y
ese es uno de los grandes desafíos que
va a tener que afrontar el siguiente
gobierno y por eso andrés garau también
tiene un plan de al mismo tiempo de la
vacunación reforzar el sistema de salud
pública porque la vacuna no se pone sola
entonces tiene que haber profesional de
salud tiene que haber formaciones tiene
que haber centros de salud habilitados y
sobre todo se tiene que dar esta vacuna
gratuita entonces la visión de la salud
pública de la revolución ciudadana es
que sea accesible universal y gratuita
así como la conocemos aquí en canadá
yo la verdad le cuento que yo tuve un
cáncer y yo tuve que sanarme aquí fui me
hospital hice hice mis tratamientos mis
exámenes consulté con médicos y no me
costó un dólar es decir que en este
sistema en el que vivimos en canadá no
se deja morir a la gente por falta de
dinero eso es un sistema de salud
público de salud pública accesible
universal y gratuito y cómo se financia
ese sistema por los impuestos yo pago
impuestos usted paga impuestos todo el
mundo pague impuestos para que el día
que usted se enferme y necesite puede ir
al hospital para que el día que hay una
crisis como la ponte con el coronavirus
se tenga un sistema de salud pública
fuerte que pueda responder a las
necesidades de su población entonces ese
es una gran debilidad en el ecuador en
este momento y es una de las prioridades
del gobierno de andrés árabes
cuán instaurando nuestra conversación
cuáles son los dos elementos las
herramientas que le permiten tener
esperanza a su hermano de ser el futuro
presidente de su país
la verdad es que la gente está muy
cansada del gobierno actual y de las
crisis que se han vivido y que se están
viviendo en ecuador se están viviendo
crisis que no se han vivido jamás y ya
hemos vivido muchas crisis sociales y
económicas pero esta es sin igual
entonces la gente está cansada ya no
creen en la política siempre es lo mismo
entonces quieren un cambio y saben que
cuando el gobierno de correa estuvo se
vivía mejor había mejores condiciones de
trabajo había más acceso a la salud
habían becas para poder educarse la
educación universal también entonces la
situación está bastante clara y hay un
apoyo popular masivo andrés araos las
encuestas lo demuestran justamente hace
23 días me parece salieron tres
encuestas autorizadas por el cn vale la
pena decirlo porque hay muchas encuestas
que no es
autorizadas por 6-3 encuestas que le dan
como ganador a andrea sagrados y son los
más recientes hay una encuesta de atlas
intel me parece que es una encuestadora
brasilera muy prestigiosa y que ha
predecido los resultados de las
elecciones en brasil en argentina y en
eeuu y ellos están también salió en la
encuesta que ellos hicieron que android
arados está en primer lugar con 36 por
ciento y que hasta es posible que gane
en una sola vuelta entonces la realidad
es de eso hay un apoyo masivo y es muy
probable que andrés ganados sea el
futuro presidente de la caja por último
no quería cerrar nuestra entrevista sin
decir que como usted ya lo ha dicho a lo
largo de nuestra conversación siendo la
hermana del posible futuro presidente de
ecuador usted vive en canadá
cuando llegó a canadá por qué y qué
piensa hacer si su hermano es elegido
piensa retornar a su país o permanecerá
aquí
yo vine a canadá en el 2007 es decir que
ya son 14 años que vivo aquí en montreal
vine para estudiar para formarme en mi
familia formarse es muy importante
mis papás han podido salir de la pobreza
gracias a la educación han podido gozar
de muchas cosas gracias a la educación
entonces la educación es un es un valor
muy importante en mi familia por eso
andrés también se ha formado como se ha
formado y ya entonces yo también vine a
estudiar acá estudié en la universidad
de montreal en francés en mi tercer
idioma
si es que andrea saraos gana estaré a su
lado donde sea que me necesite
maria josé aráoz hermana de andrés arauz
candidato a presidente de ecuador muchas
gracias por esta entrevista con radio
que nos da internacional muchas gracias
hasta les angosto